smell of money can be intoxicating not
even a year since the gruesome murder of
Washington Post journalist Jamal [ __ ]
and the worldwide condemnation over
Saudi officials suspected role in it but
it seems enough money can sway anything
throughout last week who is who of the
financial elite hunkered down together
at a Saudi financial summit I find it's
a very important and interesting place
for us to build relationship the
transformation of the region has been
quite amazing list of speakers and those
in attendance was impressive top dogs
from banks including HSBC Morgan Stanley
JP Morgan and Chase saw CTA General
former EU prime ministers the VIP real
deal now juxtapose that with the
conference the Saudis held in October
dubbed Davos in the desert that was
toxic CEOs investors made their excuses
left and right and center but not for
long because the irresistible smell of
money soon returned the fact that
there's issues in the press does not
tell me I must run away from a place
ironic given that he said that at the
Ritz Hotel in Riyadh where 18 months ago
dozens of Saudi dissidents and royal
rivals were detained apparently tortured
and forced to give up billions of
dollars to the king so who cares of an
outspoken journalist was butchered and
dissolved an acid who cares if Saudi
Arabia just executed 37 men reportedly
for political reasons crucifying one of
them those Saudi billions could be just
the thing to make America great again
Saudi Arabia very rich country we defend
them
[Music]
nothing but cash you know you had people
wanting to cut off Saudi Arabia they
bought 450 billion dollars I don't want
to lose him I called the king
I like the king I said King
we're losing or defending you King and
you have a lot of money what's bad for
business is bad for everyone so perhaps
goes without saying that with some
things it's best to forget like murder
torture mass executions and depression I
mean put yourself in their very very
expensive shoes CEO of investment firm
Blackrock manages more than six trillion
dollars in assets trillion for reference
the US government budget for next year
is just under five trillion when we're
talking about trillions of dollars human
rights and well just people generally
become a little less important that's
not to say the CEO of Blackrock is a bad
guy naina mr. Fink was recognized last
November by the crisis response group
the International Rescue Committee for
his spirit and passion for humanitarian
causes real people guy charity and all
that said the smell of money
of trillions does crazy things to you so
no you can go on boycotting and
criticizing Saudi Arabia but the guys
with the money who hold the strings
they're interested it's business as
usual
you